I'll on a very warm welcome to another
edition of talking Germany the show
where we do just that and my guest today
is the outstanding film director and
producer Nico Hoffman and here he is in
person thank you very very much for
joining us is that aren't in Germany
wonderful great stuff now it's
absolutely astonishing I can tell you
how many films nucca Hoffman has been
involved in his devotion to the business
is I think it's fair to say almost manic
and his special fascination is making
movies about Germany's difficult recent
history indeed it has been said that
nickel Hoffman is obsessed with German
history in here you're smiling a wee
little bit as I say that but it's it's
not just been said of you I have a quote
about you you said of yourself I am
obsessed by German history and then you
added to such an extent in fact that it
is not normal I did I did say that where
does it all come from actually I think
it started really buy buy my own family
stories in my minimal family and I was
trained as a journalist and during the
trading time I studied some research on
on the story of my family in in Mannheim
where I come from and in the moment
where you start to discuss the own
family background the own family
biographies you immediately come to the
part of the soutache and you ask your
parents what have you done as a soldier
what have you done it's a punt torture
matron my mother was very young she was
14 when the soutache ended and so
immediately you you start to discuss
your family stories also in the times
between 33 and 45 ok that's what we're
going to be talking about today is gonna
be very interesting let me just move on
a little bit to set out the agenda a wee
bit there was a journalist who was
writing about your work in the in the
last you know many years and he said
nikka hawkman has probably on his own
made more films about german history in
the last 10 years than all the other
people in the 40 years before yeah and
then that journalist said the
earning the yearning among Germans for
these films is almost unlimited hmm how
do you explain that yearning now I'm not
sure if it's still a yearning I would
say indeed yes in the last 15 years i
think i've produced 25 30 films touching
or directly touching the subject of the
cerclage really really a lot of them and
many of them like traceton which was
also shown in in England as I think the
BBC showed it or even much of millions
about the refugees coming directly in 45
from the eastern so-called parts of
Germany fleeing from the Russians it
true really 11 12 13 million audiences
each evening for 23 part though that was
amazing as it was amazing that there was
such a inner need for discussion about
emotional backgrounds what have happened
in those days for example people having
survived the bombardment interest they
wanted to talk in their own families
about their memories on these days and
it's amazing for me that you needed this
very special emotional filmic adaptation
of all these events that people are now
in the year Tristan was shown in 2006
that you need the film that people in
2006 were able to speak out very openly
about their feelings in those days so
this was something amazing for me but
that's a reason for the further for the
big success of all these films
you Goldman I'd like to go back to your
early days to your student days when you
were when you were at Film School you
made it you made a short movie it wasn't
quite an hour long as far as I know cold
Deer Creek minus parties yeah my
father's war whoops what was the story
there actually it was a diary from a
father about his first days in the war
that he wrote down every day and then
off of his wartime and the film was made
in a period in Germany where you had
this huge discussion about the natto
double brushless that was the idea to
put more rockets on charm and soil
against the Russians was a big d Bay it
was the first time in those days that
people in Germany really feared a new
war could could could be on the front
could be happening and the the film
school was at all my students everybody
was discussing could be it could be
could we have a subject like the war in
our first movie we are doing at the film
school and I picked I picked not the
modern questioning I picked the
questioning after the memories and after
after the experience of my own father
and that was a big debt was a beginning
of a big debate was in the film and
within the family what happened in those
days what experience emotional
experience he had it was in some ways a
starting point of generation war the big
hit that was now shown when some
advanced of phaidor three weeks ago here
exactly we'll come to that in just a
second but did your first full-length
movie we just saw a little extract from
it there in that report that was 1988 I
think you were by this time you were a
professional filmmaker by this stage you
made this movie lunch defi Atlanta's own
a land of the fathers hmm just tell me a
little bit about that one as well
because this is another movie about a
father story lender father son of sons
was the idea that the same actor playing
the Son and the father both were the
same vector so I slipped into the role
if you want so of my own of the
generation of my father and in addition
to that the film was also
he was also researching in a very
special way it was not only the story of
my own father it was a story of two
other friends of my father in Mannheim
concerning their story in the certified
so it was a really real based on fact
research story what happened in those
days it was playing in Poland part of
the film were shot in Poland but the
interesting thing for me was I was
putting myself if you want so as a
script water I was putting myself in the
same role as father and of Sun and I
played sub psychology i played the the
rhythm of the lives of the father's
through my own eyes that was idea behind
a lender father son of sons very
intriguing you've mentioned your father
already you've mentioned your mother
already we've mentioned German history
you grew up with German history literate
literally bring brought into the house
where where you were growing up your
your mother and your father were both
journalists at the time and they were
very well-connected generous they were
very very connected to the political
scene my father was working for the hind
first he was a chef from tins and he led
her on worked in Bonn he was very close
to really plan to Helmut Schmidt
especially to Helmut Kohl helmut kohl
was indeed visiting us many times he was
close living in in lyrics of him but
another another important thing was at
the Mannheim film vaca the Manama film
week was a very important festival on
those days and all the big big directors
from the eastern parts of Germany like
millet Foreman many people from Poland
we're really coming to our family really
yeah and it was it was if you want so it
was every evening we had a very very
interesting discussion with people from
all over the world about cinema about
art and about politics so that was a
very my childhood before my parents were
separated it was a very very interesting
time of my life definitely you were
initially a film director now you are a
film producer that's really how you've
made your name in
in the big market as it were why did you
make the transition yeah i was quite i
would say i was quite talented as a film
director and i had my ups and downs at
the end of the career I was sorry to see
you smiling as you think back to those
yeah it was not only easy it was it was
a yeah you have successes you have
failures but at the end of the day when
I was 35 I started in a very new film
school close to Stuttgart it's called
Film Academy baden-württemberg and I was
a teacher and I really felt that I had
so many students being more talented
than I've felt for myself it was
especially one one guy he was 22 he was
so incredibly talented and I produced
the films of them as I had 15 20
students each year I was a producer of
their student films and at the same time
I was working for banishing up and
Archana was one of the big personalities
he was number one is he still is even if
even two years after his debt he still
the german film producer of adi of
decades and he will never be replaced
and i was working for band and I got the
feeling how great and how interesting it
could be if you're really if you're
really creatively producing if you
really put all your creation into
production and that gave me within two
or three years I really got the energy
to say okay I stopped the career as a
director and irie I make a complete
reset in my life and I really restart it
was a new producing company and that was
a restart when I was such a seven and
thankful it was a very good experience
and you talk there about putting
everything into movies putting
everything maybe into a specific movie
project our mothers our fathers this
most recent project of yours are one of
the certainly the most outstanding
project here it's been much discussed
huge controversy i think is registered
as well yeah just just map out for us a
wee little bit what it's about noble of
a quick look it's it's about five young
people between 41 and 45 in germany
one of them is Jewish and two girls two
boys and the last boys Jewish he escapes
to Poland on a way towards a
concentration camp and it's their life
and their stories and it's alive like
the title is called of my of the
generation of my parents
there's a great project removing project
for me personally I would say a very
personal project for you we've
established that and it's got an awful
lot to do with your relationship with
your father as I understand it there was
one very specific day that you met with
him in New York or you spent with him in
New York tell us mother yeah it was but
my parents got separated that was a huge
divorce going on and was very hurting me
a lot and at the end of all these crazy
discussions before my father left for
another women and he went went together
with me to New York for I was 14 and we
stayed there for one week and I started
really I was very aggressive totally
aggressive and I started to talk with
him about the divorce and why he wanted
to go and why he's so crazy peaceful and
he's not struggling for me especially
and we came to the wartime experience as
we came after three days he started to
talk about his experience in life his
experience killing other people his
experience to survive we're in war times
and it was a the the topic changed from
from his personal story to his personal
story during wartime and I mean I was I
was 14 and I i was totally overwhelmed
with his feelings i couldn't get that
organized in any way what he wanted to
head understandable i understand was
like it was very tough to understand it
what she wanted it and then he left and
crazy enough in I slept two or three
weeks at the side of my mother and there
was a little bedside chair and in this
better better chair he left his photos
and his the medallions and all that
stuff he got in in wartime so everything
he left before he went to his new family
in ludwigshafen was his last
pieces of avatar memories that was crazy
i was 14 and I kept that stuff with me
for all those days and then I restarted
the process six years ago as especially
after trace in the twist so you needed
all that time to I need a giant yeah
because we had a very tricky difficult
relationship that was not easy
relationship but I really wanted I told
i told him before he would die I would
love to have this discussion longer and
longer again what where these important
years for him because these three or
four years where the most also
negatively the most awesome
psychologically very very destructive
way where the most deciding years in his
life hmm it was a 14 year old your
father tells you that he killed you just
said you didn't say a person you said
people yeah yeah yeah what does that do
to a 14 year old I mean I come from a
military family but nobody told me that
this happened I don't think it did yeah
yeah you first of all you have no
imagination what it means but the much
more problematic thing was that you know
in sherman schools and this is a very
very very okay for me it's very clear
that the Nazi crimes the since your
family have done in the Nazi time I all
all family members being connected to
the soutache in my family half of them
were conducted to the Third Watch they
they're gangsters they were not only
gangsters they were murderers they were
outcasts there were the most negative
people when you were 15 years old in
school term and you read German
literature in history lessons in school
time you immediately choose the position
of the Jewish side as a youth thing okay
if I who if I would be free to be asked
I would love to be true and not to be at
ramen so deep really so deep in the
question of guilt and it's a question of
what half has this generation done to
the whole world was in my mind so if
your own father says to you okay but I
killed Russian soldiers that was the top
of the discussion emotionally because
that was something for me I could
absolutely not let through to me
absolutely not when I was 15 years old
and one of the questions you're asking
yourself I'm sure while you're being
involved in this project is how would I
have acted at the time yeah the first
question is how would I have acted in
those days and the next question is and
there you need much more material that
was possibly here with China reservoir
is a question how could it be that the
whole nation really comes to this kind
of absolutely terrible engagement
against the whole world against Jews
against the Polish people against the
Russians this is really a question for
me perhaps it started in those days and
between school term and personal debates
within the family perhaps it was a time
where it started all over in me but
there's surely the point in my life
where this whole discussion again and it
ended if you want so with this last film
i certainly don't want to pry into your
private life but when i was reading
about you when I was researching about
you there was one thing there were a lot
of things that shocked me because we're
talking about German history and German
history is shocking that's here but
there was one thing it about you as a
person who's you you have been
traumatized by what went on between the
generations and I read that you as a
youngster this must have been at the
same time you filmed your parents having
arguments the I did that here sure that
was part of Maya this is shocking this
is shocking to me yeah I don't know if
it's shocking I mean I was studying
filmmaking with 78 years it started with
a super 8 camera and this is a typically
a lot of my film students today this
started with a video camera and there
were eight years old but in the
beginning it was just fun but cheering
the lifetime between 15 16 17 were
really all these diseases I had a very
had a very aggressive and very I would
say it's interesting discussions within
my family about everything and everybody
really i had i was struggling with my
mother i was struggling with my middle
with my father i was struggling about
their past i was struggling with my
grandmother i was very aggressive and
then the filmmaking and and to film it I
was really I was really making it really
made a film about the divorce of my
parents live in the living room of proof
of our house at linden ave manam and we
had were two actors and they were
playing for one full week all yeah all
debates all craziness i had in my family
but that was something like a therapy
and surely it was a therapy for the next
year's on film school when I was a film
student when I have and I have a look to
my former films all these films were
very very yeah a bit big kind of family
therapy in some way okay let's come back
to the to the to how you dramatize
history when you make when you make a
film out of history your father told you
the story and you're thinking I want to
tell that story that you've sometimes
being criticized for using too much
emotion mmm because history what really
happens reality is cold it's dirty it's
dark it's cruel it's unpleasant there's
no background music in your movies
there's background music people
sometimes talk of you know elements of
kitsch I know you don't like that so how
do you answer that i would say i changed
the portfolio of the films and the
making of the films in the last six or
seven years it changed dramatically if
you have a look to a film like tres noir
much of millions called defrost in
germany the structures of the films
they're very melodramatic it was a very
melodramatic structure it had a love
affair plot in the middle of the
storyline but nevertheless if you take
trace and which was the biggest
hit in selling overseas the second part
of trace and everything is about
authenticity everything you see you feel
you get in the second part is really
what's really happening interest and so
it is not kitsch it's not overwhelming
with feelings and melodramatic
structures but i changed it and if you
take the films of the last two years are
really came back to very realistic very
authentic setting if you take to a
narration for once we're on for theta
it's very authentic that the music is
very very minimalistic it's not a big
orchestral music so i changed it because
people are now I was especially saying
Germany people are now they are now
capable also intellectually capable
really to take the films even if they
are so pure and though hard so hard as
they have been here with generation
wrong it was not clear this is a success
or not a success many people in the
television companies not only on set f
sides is that this will be a tragedy if
nobody will will watch it but it was not
the case
burnout is something that you know about
yeah what can you report your an oath
question actually I had a big burn out
at about three years ago it happened
after one of the films were not so
publicly acclaimed as I wanted to have
it and it didn't work how many films
have you directed or produced produced
that's that how many a lot i would say
hundred yeah more than 100 as a we are
now I think we're nearly 300 know within
team box it so it's a it's huge but it
was a film corner one of the negative
sometimes floor sometimes sometimes
there's a firmware really i would tell
you even if China reservoir yeah when
soma don'ts of theta if it would have
been a big failure if nobody would have
watched it would have been you would
have been in tank yeah absolutely i'm
not in danger but i think i would really
in the moment if you if you invest
really a lot of time a lot of energy and
you love the project and then it's
absolutely not working you start really
to reflect okay what are the reasons mmm
was the wrong way what is the future
what should i do the future with other
topics so this was the cancer it was
wasn't the limit no the bar that was
call it the digit and in the exact
translation would be the borderline it
but I reestablished the body line
between East and West Germany my feeling
was it all comes back and I wanted to
have it as a there's a future outlook
and was was some of the parts of the
film way okay other ones were totally
crazy but the critics they hated it the
audience was quite okay at the second
part it dropped down dramatically and
that came together with really ten years
of permanent work twenty films a year
and then you get you get on some kind of
on a serial level where you really feel
have absolutely no energy anymore to
energize me and that was a reason so
yeah well what are they I mean there are
people who work hard clearly you do yeah
there are people who are called
workaholics I'm never quite sure what
that means and then there's burnout
syndrome yeah what are what you know
what are the signs that you've gone from
one to the next and into burning
I think the crucial point is if you if
you work and you don't have any more
distance to yourself into your own work
so if you verb for years and and and
sometimes you have success for three
four five years and you get the film k
that will happen till our delivery dies
I will have only success in my life and
then then you you lose any kind of
reflection any kind of distance and i
have also many friends in the literature
in the arts on the actor side a lot of
actors who really only want to be loved
by the audience and if ratings are
slipping down and they don't get any
more jobs for many of them in a special
age it become a very crucial just
discussion to say where where do I stand
and that happened so that happened and
and that took nearly one year of you
took a timeout a very long time took a
timeout and I restarted focusing i
restarted my personal life ready to take
your time out every day and every day i
have two hours when we are finishing
here the show i will have two hours
between six and eight really go to my
room just do nothing just sing about the
day today to sports and then go for
dinner and and and in those days i went
for dinner after the last meeting so i
was from nine to midnight it worse yeah
it was it was a full lifetime sorta chop
and and and that's not working with me
anymore he would top employer I am
you're absolutely sure because then you
start to have the imagination everybody
works as you know I have no family many
many many many very good people in my
company they have families and I have to
learn and I had to learn to respect that
their their time is to spend their time
with a family with their kids and so on
and I learned it and now it's a very
easy for me to say okay and then do it
okay you take the two hours of every day
that's a lot of time two hours yeah it
is really indeed it's a lot of time yeah
yeah but you are still working very very
very hard indeed and one of they've got
it you've got a new project that you're
working on I know which as far as I
understand it's going to be not just a
three-part series it's gonna be
eight-part series on the life of
adulthood which until recently was like
almost taboo terapia yeah it's taboo
territory and I did it because there was
a very interesting book from Thomas
labor Hitler's first war which I read
some very good journalist praised the
book and I read it and there are so many
interesting informations about the life
of art of Hitler about his personal
structure it gives a fully new picture
about his personality and and you know I
have through the success in the last
year's there's a certain interest with
two colleagues one is sitting in London
the other person sitting in France we
were we were talking about Hitler
project for about 10 years and now I had
the feeling that time could be okay with
all these new informations we got and
after the film's we have done in an
international co-production to go on and
hopefully it will be a quality as I
understand it from what you're saying
what you're going to do is you're going
to portray Adolf Hitler not as a demon
but as a as a human being um as well I
would say for me he is a demon and to
get the bigger life behind him doesn't
at all make him a saint or make him
anything in this direction or no way and
I mean the balance we have to find us
really to say you have the demon you
have you have the the most terrible
personality put in putting crime all
over putting death all over but I want
to understand the psychology behind him
why drama people so easily followed him
that the basic thing about
Ben Archie McHugh grew up with her with
this man in your living room effectively
yeah I didn't I mean tell us what
explain the legend to us the legend in
Germany in my generation was I mean he
was a first guy really telling the
people about nature about animal life
and he was we have the Korean party I
would say he was a first Green Party
member in his his beliefs and and he was
fascinating it was it was not only the
crazy television show man looks a little
bit totally nuts but he was he was a
fascinating personality praying the
subjects of nature how do we behave
against environment is your environment
important for us what happens to nature
in the next decade he was the first
person on TV and in real life putting
this on the agenda and the German people
he was the first one I would say
worldwide it was his television show he
saw that in many countries that the not
himself but the but the documentary
parts was salt world over and he's a
fascinating personality and charm
necessary did you ever meet him no okay
nobody i met his parts of his family
yeah ah and you met them because because
we are shooting his lifetime story
starting in october in in south africa
yep okay um justjust for me it is a
source of constant fascination when way
to one we're making the kind of films
that you make when people are making
those kind of films and you've made so
many of them I often wonder we're
talking about mr. Jim McKeon and he won
an Oscar for a documentary film yeah why
do you not conclude sometimes that a
documentary film would be a better way
of transporting reality than a than a
drama a feature film yeah you know the
interesting thing is I first of all I
came from journalism and then I studied
in Munich oh I switched from the fiction
croup the documentary crew by was was
four years in the documentary section of
the school and you know all of the films
in the last year's they were always
correspondent together always put
together with the documentary afterwards
if you had
generation voir you have two documentary
on the tetteh f sides after the film and
in the last year's i also used parts of
documentaries within the film so i
really try if you talk about authentic
authentic see if you talk about real
feelings in those days i really try to
match it with material i can get even in
generation war we had a lot of material
in from charman from from from water and
shower and it was under and it was
overlaid with some with the struggling /
voice from from bogota who was playing
here the main actor none so i used it so
i used it many many times okay let's
draw a conclusion a wee little bit
you've made all these movies lots of
them lots of movies about german history
the German news magazine Der Spiegel
called you the person in charge of
significance in German television yeah
it's a grand idea describe the impact
you've had I would say Joanna dilorenzo
from his editor of the tide he told me
that two weeks ago I really think if you
take all the films i have made in the
last 10 12 years if you take trace and
if it takes doubt and berg I mean
Stauffenberg was also seen by tom cruise
before he made his movie if you take all
the things I've done about if it takes a
the tool about the introspection how
people live just a very very good mood I
loved it yeah it was based on over
telecoms but I would really say if I put
together the audience's we talked about
millions of people having seen these
programs it surely has an impact of how
about how people in Germany are talking
about their history and their personal
memories in their history so hopefully
it has a positive aspect to say we can
talk more openly about our lives here in
Germany ok checking up that point we
normally have a quiz at this stage in
the show i'm going to give you one
question yeah do we learn from history
or repeat it
I was ever alone that's good news I hope
you're right I hope you're right that's
your lot with the the charming the
thought-provoking nikka Hawkman there's
more talking Germany including my blog
blog on our archived on our website have
a look at that but for now I'm just
going to say it's been a great show if
you've enjoyed it as much as I have come
back next week just bye-bye
you
you